ahora quiero hablar un poco del concepto
de retroalimentación el concepto de
utilizar retroalimentación es muy
importante y fue desarrollado en los
años 1920 en los laboratorios
laboratorios bell
los bell teléfonos laboratories recuerda
que hablamos de esto en los
amplificadores operacionales siendo esta
la entrada no inversora si este voltaje
sube este también sube y el signo
negativo es la entrada inversora así que
este voltaje y éste se mueven en
direcciones opuestas y la clave para
entender lo que es la retroalimentación
es poner atención a esta entrada
inversora y ya está no inversora
empecemos por aquí únicamente aislando
la parte del divisor de voltaje de
nuestro circuito eso se copió acá
veamos qué sucede si el voltaje de
salida asciende qué pasa con b - en este
caso en qué dirección va de menos en un
divisor de voltaje va hacia arriba esta
es una estructura no inversora si el
voltaje de salida sube entonces el valor
que nos importa que es b - también sube
de la misma manera si el voltaje de
salida baja entonces ve - baja
eso nos queda al aislar solo esta parte
no tenemos inversión ocurriendo aquí
alrededor ahora vayamos para acá y
veamos lo que sucede en esta vía si
asciende el voltaje de entrada entonces
el voltaje de salida sube si luego
cambiamos colores para intentemos esto
si ve - sube entonces el voltaje de
salida baja esa es la vía inversora hay
una inversión en este circuito ocurre
justo aquí donde ve - va al voltaje de
salida es allí donde está la inversión
ahora déjame armar solo un circuito como
ejemplo
digamos que hereu no es igual a 2
y del último vídeo desarrollamos una
expresión de ganancia y dijimos que el
voltaje de salida
es igual a r 1 +
r2 sobre r2
por el voltaje de entrada
y con estos valores de resistencias el
voltaje de salida
es igual a dos veces el voltaje de
entrada
muy bien entonces esto es igual a dos
veces el voltaje de entrada
y cómo se afecta a este punto de aquí ve
- este es ve - y de nuestro divisor de
voltaje sabemos que nuestro divisor de
voltaje dice que ve - es igual al
voltaje de entrada
por r2 que simplemente ere sobre ere más
ere
o de menos es igual
un medio
el voltaje de salida
pongamos un voltaje aquí pongamos un
voltaje real aquí digamos que está a un
bolt está bien y viendo nuestro
amplificador
sabemos que el voltaje de salida es
igual a 2 volts y eso significa que ve -
es igual a un medio del voltaje de
salida así que ve - es igual
porta hay un bol está aquí
digamos por ahora que algo le pasó a
este circuito que lo calentamos o algo
por el estilo y digamos que la ganancia
sube un poco ahora lo que esto significa
es que este amplificador que está
amplificando esta diferencia de voltaje
de aquí estará un poco elevada para que
el voltaje de aquí suba un poco
utilicemos este color a sube un poco y
esto significa que este voltaje de
salida subirá un poco y ya hemos
decidido al observar este divisor de
voltaje que si este punto sube este
punto subirá
subir a la mitad del total- pero irá
hacia arriba cuando este voltaje sube
esto significa que este voltaje sube
y ahora nos encontramos en la entrada
impresora del amplificador y eso
significa que cuando el cambio en la
entrada inversora sube eso significa que
la salida baja
esa es la dirección opuesta del cambio
original este es el mecanismo de
retroalimentación cuando a su vez
pensamos que el voltaje de salida sube
un poco que significa que este punto
sube que significa que retroalimenta la
entrada inversora y baja nuevamente
este balance que ocurre aquí eso es a lo
que llamamos retroalimentación obtienes
este efecto de retroalimentación cuando
se hace aquí esta conexión de regreso a
la entrada inversora del op amp y
particularmente debido a esta entrada
inversora
esto es llamado red
y meditación
y la diva
este es el mecanismo de
retroalimentación particularmente
retroalimentación negativa y lo que hace
por nosotros es darnos una manera de
aprovechar y usar esta enorme ganancia
que tienen los amplificadores para crear
circuitos estables muy controlados que
dependan de los valores de los
componentes que conectamos al
amplificador esa es la retroalimentación
ideal es un concepto muy poderoso y es
una base de la electrónica analógica